Rhonda santis demands ilen Omar is
thrown out of Congress and deported
following speech declaring she is
Somalia first as she faces calls to
resign yo this is wild did you guys see
the speech from Elan Omar she's not
she's basically literally insane she's
talking to a bunch of somalis saying our
president my president my country things
like this saying that we're going to
fight for our country and people are
like whoa whoa whoa like she is she is
speaking like she is not an American
citizen we are going to invade Kenya
yeah people were talking about how in
the past she's been bullhorn saying
Somalia my country and then corrects
herself so Ronda santis he's got a tweet
he said expel from Congress denaturalize
and Deport wow uh I just I just got to
say this is like I don't know how you
describe it what Ronda Santa said is
more
politically what's the right word for
this fiery yeah spicy than what maybe
anyone has said in politics the sitting
governor of Florida called for stripping
a US citizen of her citizenship and
sending her back to the country she
claims to have allegiance to look
dropping out of the race was a great
thing for him he's feeling more
confident he's feel yeah he's like my
political career is over the
EXP the expulsion definitely needs to
happen though El Omar has done this over
and over she's constant embarrassing the
United States ironically enough the
Democratic party they're crazy to even
have her aboard at this point and you
know that some of the neoliberals would
like to see her gone but she's a an
ethnic female she practices Islam they
don't want to touch that with a 50ft
pole they don't want they don't want to
lose their clout their it's not just
that it's that ill Omar represents a
very Somali District so she has local
she's Untouchable exactly yeah they're
they're going to keep voting her in
there is potential competition for her
from a more conservative perspective you
if you got someone who is like Muslim uh
Somali but they were conservative not
Progressive I think they would win but
you'd still have to have someone
basically preaching to the group of
people that they represent Somalia and
not Minnesota but that's where we're at
so anyway Ron has uh uh as you said it
was very good for him to drum out of the
race I wonder what would have happened
if he said things like this while he was
running perhaps he should
have his support probably would risen if
he had said something like that about El
Omar yeah I think so I think that this
is sort of more fiery than he was
because the big accusation was that he
didn't have a personality yeah he sort
of he was sort of a limp noodle at times
when he was running I I think he was
trying to like counterbalance himself
against like Trump's mean tweets or
something like that it just didn't work
what could you imagine what Trump
supporters would be saying if Ronda STIs
tweeted this would they be forced to
defend ilhan Omar just to be an
opposition to santis
some uh some of the real hardcore
influence ERS would have you believe
that I would have laughed my ass off oh
yeah no for sure I feel like if he had
Tweet stuff like this it would have left
the door open to him having a position
in in the Trump Administration whereas
then things got too tense there's too
much there's there's too much that's
happened now whereas if he had said
stuff like this they would have felt
more aligned I I think I think there's
still a possibility to santis ends up in
the Trump adist I I I could see him as
being uh in the cabinet maybe not his
running mate cuz again well they can't
both be florid right he's a little bit I
mean if he's making tweets and and
like this then he's too charismatic for
Trump to have his a running man right I
I got to be honest I do believe that
there's a handful of trump personalities
Trump supporters where if Ron tweeted
that while running they would say oh
come on I mean like we're all critical
of illan but the idea of stripping
someone from their CI citizenship is
fascist Ron is a fascist now they're
going to be like based there would be
some Trump support there there are
always going to be a few hardcore fans
who get cognitive dissonance of course
absolutely no yeah yeah of course I I
would have should have said this i'
would have been like yes
Ron break from your cocoon become who
you were meant to be Trump you have
found your running mate cuz where does
he go from here I I feel like I asked
this every other day but you know I feel
like he's going to start a podcast on
Rubble he'd make more money he's gonna
join us here in alternative media he
really you should try to get Ronda
Santa's aboard well he his campaign
banned banned their staff from appearing
on show if he comes to our regular event
you know it' be funny like could you
imagine why would they have bad blood
with your show this like the natural
place would fit was too trumpy and we
are friends with some of like uh like
Will Chamberlain worked for him and and
Will's a friend a good friend and he's
been on the show several times uh but
there were uh attempts had been made we
can't reach out to their people and they
were just like they kept saying no and
then we got word that basically that s
his campaign said do not go on Tim cast
IRL which is the weirdest thing I think
they would have gotten more votes if
they they would have and I think what
happens is they were getting advice from
you know like the Ken Griffin types
these establishment Rhino you know stagi
unaa Party Guys Lindy Graham gave him a
call yeah and they're like go on CNN go
on cable TV the podcasts aren't real and
then look at V ramaswami VI saw what
what VI was probably sitting there and
he was like Ron's doing everything wrong
I'm going to do what he should do and
it's going to work and it did he was
never going to be president I told the
that
and you know we had him on the culture
War show earlier uh last year and I said
to him I'm a fan of a he's a great guy I
said I don't think you're going to win I
would like to vote for you in the
primary but I think Trump's going to win
anyway and he's like well you know look
I'm running we'll see blah blah blah but
I'm like come on a a firsttimer young
guy with no political background at 0%
is is is very very very very unlikely to
win a GOP nomination especially with
Trump running as an effective incumbent
I think anybody who thought they were
anyone else was going to beat Trump in
this is is delusional except when V said
they are going to stop at nothing to
remove Trump in which case I should stay
in this as long as I can the crazy thing
is dude spent like $30 million of his
own money what was the number was it 30
million I know he sold I think it was
more than that actually yep of his own
money trying to maintain this I respect
it and then what did he do once Iowa
came up bad he he bowed out and endorsed
Trump right away masterfully played Ron
could have done all that and Ron didn't
but I just I just want to say this how
hilarious would it be if after the
election Rhonda santis is termed out
he's he's done he doesn't run he just
comes out and he's like I'd like to
thank the people of Florida the good
people who supported me as I was your
Governor uh I now want to say go to
rumble.com Rond DeSantis to watch my new
show where I talk about stripping
immigrants of their citizenship and
deporting them back to their home
countries we're going to build the wall
and then he just goes totally off and he
makes this like you know graper Rumble
Channel and he is just like super you
know we're going to build the borders
for funding gone I've always wondered
why people when when they get like so
much money and and so much clout that
clearly you know they've got a
continuing career they'll always be able
to pay their bills but none of them ever
like go crazy and start doing like crazy
stuff and saying crazy things or only
very rarely and it's actually a mystery
because you could get even more
attention doing that and it's like you
could Corner the market this is this is
listen listen this is why I want
everyone to go to facts rap.com fs
rap.com and buy Tom McDonald and Beno
song I really do mean it um like you
know talking to these guys seeing where
they're at it's looking where they're at
it's looking really really good but
there's a reason why I want Ben Shapiro
to hit the Billboard Hot 100 it's like
you're
saying people don't do crazy things it's
all stodgy routine and boring nothing is
shocking the system nothing is waking
people up we got to get a little weird
with it like Frank Reynolds and it's
always son he's old I mean for those of
you that have seen the show he's an old
guy he's super rich and he decides to
live in squalor with these like
degenerate bar owners because he's like
I want to get I only got a few years
left of my life I want to get freaky
with and just do weird stuff I'm not
saying to literally you know have
everyone be degenerates but one thing
I've often said is you got a lot of
powerful influential people on our side
who believe in Freedom Liberty
meritocracy responsibility they're not
spending their money doing anything
they'll go on their shows and they'll
say stuff like it's so bad that I see
Joe Biden doing this man we got to get
out there and vote good thing I'm glad
they're doing it and then they'll be
like so make sure you go to my website
you know corn starch. and buy the
cornstarch and I'm like it's fine
sponsorship supports the show but
outside of being a fire brand and a
preacher for good issues what are people
doing to actually invade to to to like
we're not going to win a culture War by
standing on a Hilltop screaming you have
to actually try and seize territory in
culture and and physical reality
so I'm I I just I get frustrated when I
see prominent individuals who become
extremely successful in news media
podcasting and then they just sit down
in their chair and they do nothing
they're like I'm good I I I've seen
people stable off they're like well I I
make I'm making good money right now I'm
going to do nothing else and I'm gonna
and I'm going to work a couple hours a
day and then I'm going to go sit on the
beach all day and I'm like man it's like
once they got comfortable and they got
money they said I don't want to move
from this position I I want to see
people with these big shows being like
I'm going to work 20 hour days 16 hour
days and we're going to win this culture
War we need more of that if Ben chapiro
and Tom M tonnell get to the Hot 100 do
you think they'll release a remix
featuring Ronda STIs no I think that
would be the funnest thing I do want to
say this in in essence we've already won
that cultural battle and it's one that
you know Carter and I have been fighting
for for for over a year now because it's
not just about politics it's about how
the industry keeps out anyone who's not
a part of the club just in general so
they change the metrics they say oh we
don't count this anymore we don't count
that because they don't like the fact
that independent individuals can build
something to challenge The Establishment
the woke establishment and their
narrative control and take
over it's going to be real funny I mean
it already is funny that bench air is
the number one rapper in the world on
iTunes but it's gonna be real funny when
hepped he he he doesn't he just talks
fast so He pry good though it's this
year is already off the hook yeah we're
only in January but but again this is
why you know for one Tom McDonald has
been putting out a bunch of really
amazing stuff for a long time
challenging the culture and it's funny
what they say they're like here's a guy
who looks like a drug dealing gang
banger and he's rapping against this
stuff and I'm like duh that's the point
that you you you you do not have to
combine the style the looks the
aesthetic with being a criminal you can
be a good person and try and look a
certain way and have fashion so every
time he's been getting big he's been
getting big hits forever they block him
out they lie they create reasons as to
why he shouldn't chart why he doesn't
deserve to get written up about and this
guy Tom McDonald has got numerous songs
just all of them hitting like 10 20
million or not all of them but a lot of
them and you get people in the industry
now acting like they don't know who he
is the reality is they know who he is
they do not want any of us to be able to
supplant their machine but I want to let
everyone know the good
news the digital media industry is in
freef Fall Absol Tech crunch just La a
bunch people off by this time next year
it's going to be nothing left but us so
we are winning and I'm glad to see it
and what I'm hoping for now is with
things like Public Square we're now
seeing the expansion of these uh these
Public Square esque companies companies
that believe in American values
sponsoring more and more people in
various Industries it's about time these
big companies that are on Public Square
find some musicians to sponsor find some
athletes to sponsor find some drivers to
sponsor I saw a pro athlete at uh uh
Nitro Circus wearing a Public Square
shirt Nitro Circus has people on BMXs
and rollerblades and skateboards doing
back flips and scooters that means
you've got little kids hanging out in
the audience and they see a they see a
big Public Square Banner Travis Pastrana
I think he might be on Black Rifle
that's us winning and dominating we have
to build things so it's silly I guess to
be like Ben shapir is the number one
rapper we need more than that more than
coffee companies every podcast in the
world selling coffee nowadays but what
we're doing we've got a physical
location being built right now for our
coffee shop
the club will probably probably be open
in a few months so much sooner than the
actual coffee shop we're going to be
doing the live show on March 5th at the
C brew club in Martinsburg West Virginia
so the goal here is to build physical
locations where people can meet up and
then you don't need me to sit here in
front of a camera and tell you what to
think you guys can go talk to each other
long story short people who are
successful in the space need to build
things and work 10 times harder than
they are yeah there are a lot of people
that sort of sit on their Laurels I mean
look at uh even in this might not be an
example you'd even agree with look at
Howard Stern for example the man spends
the better part of two decades fighting
against censorship I mean out of
self-interest it wasn't out of any major
ideological principles then once he gets
his break he's got the contract signed
he's got all the money in the world well
bye he just uh he just uh goes off and
starts becoming boring exactly and Ary
gets fired although he was on heroin so
that sort of I mean look at look at uh
uh Jimmy Kimmel The Man Show
mhm having women jump on trampolines
there are a million memes about his his
hypocrisy yep too many people are
grifters and the funny thing is the left
likes to call people uh
anti-establishment anti-establishment
people grifters as if it's easier to be
anti-establishment as opposed to being
protected by the censorship machine we
were talking to Steve Baker yesterday
journalist who's being criminally or
they're trying to criminally charge over
January 6 he said there were three
journalists who were together and went
in the capital and filmed things one of
the guys worked for a local news outlet
with a big local news Outlet camera and
he filmed a bunch of stuff the other guy
filmed on his phone the guy filmed on
his phone released a report for the New
Yorker calling them insurrectionists M
no charges or I think uh yeah what
happened he didn't get charged at all I
or he got very light sentence if
anything I think he got nothing he said
I think he didn't get charged I think
they were just like oh you're good and
then the guy with the big news camera
got what he get eight months yeah and he
he comes home to his news station and
saying like I got all this footage I'm
like great then they cut him off and
stopped talking to him and then they
raided his house and arrested him
despite the fact he is a credential
member of the press with a press camera
with journalists filming that's that
that's the game so for all these people
like Howard Stern they know Butters
their bread they are weak pathetic
individuals and that's all that's all
they've got is I will do whatever you
say they're they're you know they're
they're Anakin Skywalker getting all
this great power and then dropping to
their knees for the emperor and saying I
will do whatever you say I don't want to
lose lose what I got cowards I mean I
think that's why you were saying before
some of these people come off campaigns
why don't they do something Bolder and I
always think it's because ultimately
they want back into the machine they
aren't sure if if things are over and
that might shift now I mean you guys
would be better able to gauges than I
would give in both of your careers but
because Alternative forms of content and
media have really become dominant
they've they're they're not just
something some people are doing they are
actual viable careers maybe we'll see a
difference now but but I think that risk
of not only am I going to lose potential
income sources but also I'm going to
lose my position where I have influence
scares people from doing anything bold
well the other thing is if you create an
infrastructure in which like non-woke
individuals who don't have a problem
with edgy content or or something
dissident something that goes against
the grain if they engage in business
making and so forth and then reinvest in
other people too you can create sort of
a lexicon of income of support in which
you don't have to have that sort of
self-censorship anymore because you've
got sort of the platforms Etc uh you've
got like new tech you've got like Rumble
bitshoot Etc uh you've got people who
are capable of investing and they expect
a return on investment and then you have
people who give them that return and
it's sort of just a reciprocal process
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net and we'll see you all next
time